Speaker 1: I spoke last week with Angelo Carusone
for Media Matters and we talked about the escape
hatch that right wing media and many Republicans
have set up for themselves when it comes to Donald
Trump and 2024. It looks as though the Murdoch
family, through news corporations, the New York
Post is pulling the ripcord on the escape hatch,
publishing a front page piece Trump did dumpty
depicting Donald Trump as a swollen, headed Humpty
Dumpty, saying Don, who couldn't build the wall,
had a great fall. Can all the GOP's men put the
party back together again? This is a piece. It's
an opinion piece in the New York Post by John
Podhoretz. And John Podhoretz calls the piece,
here is how Donald Trump sabotaged the Republican
midterms or whoever picked the title called
it that. Often it's not the writer. And points
out that Donald Trump has had three consecutive
elections in which he has arguably been a drag, if
not a downright disaster for the Republican Party.
Think of it. Donald Trump won the presidency
in 2016, riding on a number of different things
that included, of course, James Comey opting
to do a second press conference to talk about
Hillary Clinton. For some reason we still haven't
figured out and many other factors Trump won in
2016. Genuinely, he really won 2018. Didn't go
nearly as well for Republicans as historically.
Maybe it should have 2020 Trump straight up lost.
And they lost everything. They lost the House,
the Senate and and the White House in 2020 and
now in 2022. I know Trump is saying, oh, I'm 215,
I have to 200 of endorsements I got right and 15
I got wrong. But as I've told you before, it's
very easy to run up the score when you're mostly
endorsing incumbents and Republican nominees in
safe red districts. But on the critical races,
that would make a difference. Michigan Governor.
Pennsylvania Governor. Pennsylvania Senate.
Georgia Senate. We have the list, right?
Trump's record is not very good in 2022 and Rupert
Murdoch and his family seem to be saying we're
out. Couple of different things that are important
to think about here. My concern with all of this,
I don't really care. I don't care at all about
the Murdoch family. News Corp, FOX News, the
internal deliberations of the Republican Party.
Ronna McDaniel I don't care about any of these
people. I think they're all horrible. I think it's
a misguided movement. My concern is what would be
the most damaging scenario to themselves? How
can they themselves damage themselves the most?
Is it Trump announces on Tuesday that he's running
for president and everybody gets out of the way?
Does that now lead to two years of further
humiliation and another big loss in 2024,
if that's the worst case scenario for
Republicans, that's the one I want.
On the other hand, is a very snappy end and
sort of a low brow battle between Trump and
DeSantis for the Republican Party for the next
two years. The most damaging thing to Republicans,
which will weaken them and make them crumble
and erode such that they get crushed in 2024.
That's my concern. Whatever is the worst thing
for them is what I want to see happen right now.
It seems as though the infighting is good for the
left and good for Democrats and Trump is already
attacking Ron DeSantis. We'll talk about that
a little bit later. And there are many reasons
to think that the Murdochs now feeling free to
pull the ripcord is a good thing. We're going
to talk about this plenty more. We're linking
to the piece by John Podhoretz. I know it's
The New York Post, but the whole point is
it's interesting to see how even they now
are portraying Trump. And specifically,
I now want to talk about Pennsylvania.